what
good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast happy Thursday hope everyone's
having a great day today is a very
special unexpected episode of course
Jackie's in New York you would expect me
and Jax in studio
um but Harry takes priority and Harry's
sick Harry needs to go to the doctor yes
so of course our number one priority
here at the toast is protecting rodini
of course so that's why God gave me so
many sisters right I could just rotate
them in when I needed one so the
satchelor is here is here snacks hi you
doing I'm good how are you thanks for
having me thank you so much for being
here on such short notice I appreciate
it Jackie appreciates it Harry
appreciates it The Toasters appreciate
it of course
um and I feel like you know it's
actually been a minute since this
bachelor gave us some of her time I know
I was thinking about it on my way here
when the last time I did it was and I
don't probably maternity leave oh oh
yeah it was I was thinking it was
obviously before Jackie moved right but
I don't know when so thanks for being
here how are you doing I'm great are you
nervous no like literally not at all I
am because for some reason like I don't
know what the [ __ ] your interests are
like that was so not true I know I was
trying to pick story when it comes to
pop culture not in like life no I'm
interested in everything pop culture
besides Housewives I know I just don't
know why I can't see you sitting down
having a conversation about like the
Royals or Whoopi Goldberg you know
putting the kibosh on any future biopics
about her life well yeah I don't really
care about that like I feel like
um the youngins like the young stuff I
was looking for like Tick Tock drama you
but there really wasn't a lot so I tried
to cater the stories to your interests
today you know what should be a story
was the way that Addison Ray I looked at
that event she looked stunning yeah
that's that's that should be a story is
Addison Ray your favorite young person
of the moment
oh that's such a good question no
because I feel like she's just been like
doing her own thing I don't really know
what she's up to what about Jenna Ortega
she's having a moment I haven't watched
Wednesday yet me neither but I want to
though I want to learn the dance yeah
um oh I have to think about that who
have I been like our resident young
person I know she's getting old though I
know by the way I used to be the
resident young person yeah it's like so
sad
um there's so much to discuss the first
is that yesterday's episode Bombshell
interview with dumwa people were
obsessed I listened my friends were
texting me about it no it was like like
kind of a big deal yeah um and it did
then fuel a lot of the conspiracy
theories that I am dumois because I
wasn't here I mean did you even think
about that I didn't but then when dumwa
came on and was saying how she thinks
I'm so funny like that does sound like
something I would say about myself right
but you don't have the same voice no no
and a lot of people were shook by her
voice I I don't know why I've listened
to content of hers where I thought she
was using like a voice disguising and
that's what anti did right but she was
using her real voice and a lot of people
said she sounded like Olivia
and she did yeah if anyone in this
family could be dumwa it would be Olivia
you guys are looking at the wrong sister
yeah I'm two thousand percent like she
you guys don't even know like Olivia
what she's capable of is Dumas no I know
yeah but obviously she's not but
yesterday's episode did not help stop
the theories about our family being
connected were we trying to even stop
them though really no and honestly it
was just fortuitous timing because I
next week I haven't even said this yet
I'm moderating moderating
um like an interview for dumois her book
is coming or came out and so I was like
already in communication with her and
then we had this opening so it's
fortuitous timing but again people are
just not gonna believe me like people
are just sitting here convincing me I'm
Dwight and you know what I'm down for it
because like I'm ready for some
conspiracy theories about me a thousand
percent if like that if that's what
people are thinking about you I'm
obsessed fabulous amazing
um and we also need to recap just like
hey what's going on in this snatchler's
life because it's it's a lot
um and last night we went to the tpg
awards yeah we did and it was a fabulous
evening we looked stunning we really we
turned out I know because like I was not
feeling stunning like when I was
beginning my journey of glamor and then
I arrived at the destination and I was
shocked so the tpg awards is a fabulous
event that happens every year except
obviously we've missed the last two
because of kovid
um and let's talk about the last time
you were at the tpg awards like why do
we have to bring this up oh you don't
want to no we can't I think it's a funny
story and like you've come so far in
your journey as a woman I know in my
journey as I a woman of caring yeah as I
say about the fact that it was a cute
ass outfit okay so the last tpg Awards
was what 2019.
yes or maybe 2018 no 2019. 2019.
um and counselor did not have a good
time no because the theme of the event
was like space cadet something space
something whatever no one decided to go
in theme but didn't matter because I had
this dress it was like so cute and it
was like definitely out there and I
paired it with a pair of like
um silver like boots that were like
giving Xenon and you took a risk I took
a fashion risk and that's what young
people should do especially young people
with perfect bodies like thank you go
for it
um and like honestly like in the grand
scheme of things like it wasn't like
that [ __ ] crazy of an outfit it
wasn't like what I feel like if I wore
that now like nude yeah
um but anyway so I like Warren like you
know was getting ready to go like posted
like you know I always post like a
singing Story on Instagram with my
outfit and like and usually the comment
like my DMs in like seconds are flooded
like I'm gonna do amazing link link yeah
no that's just not what happened they
read you to Phil they've read me two
filth
um and like then I'm so and also by the
way this is my first time I think like
walking any sort of carpet like he was
like Getty like it was my first Getty
image so I got that and then I'm going
into it and I'm just like obviously
feeling like disgusting because why
wouldn't I right
um and then like I it just ruined my
night like I couldn't have fun like I
couldn't tear myself away from my phone
um so I left okay turn around and this
[ __ ] is gone yeah I just and then I
went home crying in the Uber and you
can't let anyone attack your piece like
that I don't think I would let it get to
me like that now no me neither I was
young and impressionable then I'm a
[ __ ] now yeah no and also like then
once when you don't feel confident in
your look whether it's because you just
don't like it or has been told people
that made you feel bad about it there's
really nothing that will ruin your piece
and like destroy your self-worth in
seconds more than that seconds and
Jackie once said to me when we were
younger I was crying over something like
stupid and she was like and people were
I think you guys were like you're
something so dumb but you guys are just
like trying to cheer me up whatever and
she she was like it's not very easy to
go from to in seconds it's not very easy
to go so sad to happy like it's
incredibly difficult it's very easy to
go from happiness of course in a second
yeah um well you looked fabulous last
night we really both did yeah we did for
me like the major takeaway of the event
was I have to see Betty Who in concert
again yeah and listen to her new album I
was not prepared for the level of
stanhood I followed her on Instagram
last night like I'm upset she fell back
no sorry she's busy no by the way I
didn't follow her so that she would
follow me back yeah I followed her so
like I wouldn't forget about her and
that you would be like targeted to know
about like new music right like did you
know she was opening up for panic at the
Disco this year like that would have
been a fabulous concert oh my God I
didn't know that right and also like I
do actually like Betty who is on
snatcher songs like she does come up on
my release radar but yeah I guess I'm
not as invested as I should be she's
such a performer I mean she's the best
answer I've ever seen she's such an
incredible dancer and I feel like that
happens they have amazing performances
every year at that event and I always
leave with like a new found respective
rexa I was shook at a she was Brian let
us meet her she was so cool and nice
yeah and two I was really shook because
this was like four years ago at how many
songs I knew like she really had this
like great catalog sure then Carly Rae
Jepsen I was just like pop queen icon
like I've left with like a newfound
respect and the same happened with Betty
Who when Brian said she was um coming I
was like great I'll know like one song
But like I so this was the third tpg
Awards yeah
it's a fifth year that they do it but
two years in a row was virtual because
of covid did I not go to the first one
or something no I was act all three I'm
trying to remember what I wore Bebe rexa
space cadet was two year two yeah
okay what did I wear your one need to
know something obviously that was not
memorable in a good or a bad way yeah
probably like a black dress yeah but
that that is how I remember moments in
life yeah what I wore or like what I
just like looked like at the time what
kind of haircut I had how much I hated
myself yeah yeah level of yeah
self-hatred
um so I just love Betty Who and I just I
want good things for her me too and
she's cool and nice she was so cool and
nice and like it can be easy to like do
a corporate event you know no and by the
way we were talking about how like she's
so tall
yeah and so her album is called big and
the lead single is like a song about how
like it's called Big it's so good and
the Lead Out song is a it's called Big
yeah it's about finishing my sentence
yeah and it's about being tall and how
like her whole life it was like the
worst thing like and it plagued her now
she's so proud of it it was like kind of
beautiful no I know and it's also about
that song and she is really tall yeah
and she's just like she carried herself
with this cool energy like I'm obsessed
yeah yeah she's just like a cool girl
like she definitely is like funny and
like can hang
yeah
so it's a fabulous night a fabulous
event
um am I prestigious you know it was very
prestigious yeah it was very legit I
always forget because Brian's like our
friend and he's like a brother I was
saying the same thing I forget he runs
and started like a multi-million dollar
company same like I keep talking about
like the things that they've
accomplished in like their Sizzle videos
of like all the [ __ ] that they've done
I'm like
when no it's like they like like they
had all these videos like these packages
about like the charitable things they've
done this year the Milestones they've
reached the number of people who've
clicked on their website and it's like
Brian's Brian but he's also literally
the founder of what the the biggest
travel company in the world it's crazy I
always forget I know because he's just
Brianna yeah it's crazy it's crazy
um right before we're gonna dive into
the stories and we also doing deer
toasters so we'll get a Young Person's
advice on you know what the toasters are
going we do ask the snatch on snatcher
so like we you have experience have
experience and I don't want to be
repetitive because I know so many of the
people here listen to your podcast the
snatchler available anywhere you get
your podcast new episode dropped today
um but you were talking about a story on
your podcast that you were just telling
me about I haven't listened to your
episode yet and I absolutely need you to
say it again because it's Margaret went
on was it the worst I think it might
have been I think atop the list of the
worst date I've ever been on even the
guy who was like judging you for having
drinks
oh yeah because like that guy was like
at least I kind of obsessed with me like
this guy was just me yeah okay so Margo
said she went on the state with the guy
and they fought the whole time and I'm
like how do you fight with someone you
don't know no like it was great when I
got home I couldn't sleep because my
blood was boiling I was so aggravated I
tell like the full story on this natural
but I was like get like a little bit
like because like I literally I took
notes as to why it was like the worst
date ever like yeah throughout the day
no no I was just like doing a mental
thing and then I called my friend on the
way home and was re like regurgitating
everything that happened and wrote it
down as that happened because I didn't
want to forget
um but no so I went on today with this
guy and I mean just to start which
I have to say all my locks updates have
been terrible oh shots fired um she got
fired at lox Club but no not actually
but
um what are your thoughts on this so we
went for drinks it was like a Tuesday
night and we got it's like a nice place
we went to Monkey Bar oh nice yeah and
no reservation oh I hate okay it is
worth mentioning like when it comes if
that was the only bad thing that
happened then I wouldn't care but no
that's not like a deal breaker or
anything one it just shows like a lack
of like drive and like excitement about
our date that really would annoy me but
mostly because and I've only been on one
date in my life and the entire time
leading up to the date I was so worried
about like the logistics of like getting
to the table because standing around
waiting for a table is not ideal when
I'm like with you but like when you were
the stranger it's so awkward like people
bumping you and like you need to talk
and like stand and look at each other
and also like you cover a lot of the
small talk then that once you do finally
sit down it's like what the [ __ ] do you
talk about no totally so that would
bother me for that reason not because I
I don't like waiting but because
logistically like the logistics of dates
are the worst part it get like the more
you go on them like now I don't really I
used to like worry about logistics all
the time like do I motion like all the
stuff like the more I go on it like no
like do you motion for your wallet never
no if you're asking to take me out for
drinks I will never offer and here's a
question I think I know the answer too
have you ever asked anyone out on a date
like a man no no yeah I didn't think so
no no I I again I say this all the time
on the toast I'm like a big time I
Empower women
yeah except when it comes to the
Hallmark Channel like I don't want women
CEOs I want women in the kitchen
um and when it comes to dating too like
Courtney Courtney yeah also I think it
was 50 Cent who was on um he was on like
a late night interview when he was
talking about a date and I think with
Stephen Colbert he was like who pays
when you go out on a date and he's like
whoever asked for the date and I
actually think that's a great policy
honestly because the men are going to
ask out yeah exactly that's why I just
said that I was like you asked me out
like you asked me for drinks you should
pay for it okay so he didn't make a
reservation okay so then like everything
that I I said like he was like fighting
me on and like questioning me on like
just listening to the Snapchat I'm not
gonna go into the whole thing but the
one specific one that I was telling
Claudia about was he kept talking about
um like credit cards and like points and
miles and like whatever and I was like
oh like do you know who the Points Guy
is like you should follow him which
would be a great resource okay like were
you being like a name dropper no I
didn't say I was like no Brian Kelly no
I said do you know the points guys and
he was like yeah of course I know who
the Points Guy is and I was like well
then I wanted to be an [ __ ] so then
you wanted to win again so then I was
like oh like I was just at his house in
PA this weekend like we're very good
friends with him and he was like
did you just say PA and I was like yeah
and he was like well I was born in PA
and people who are from PA don't call it
PA he just did and I was like well
Brian's from PA and he calls a PA which
is why I call it PA so like clearly
people in PA called up yeah he's like
you're so New York like let's go to FL
and I was like so
no one calls it up people call it PA
yeah and also even if they don't shut up
no that's not like a that no like so
nitpicky I hate this map no oh I mean
Beyond there were so many other things I
just was like so obviously you're not
going out with him again no he texts me
after he's like nice meeting you and I
want to be like was it was it and so how
do you um end something like that like
you just don't respond to him or he
didn't ask you out again like do you
think he hated you as much as you hated
him I don't know if he hated me as much
um because also I have a feeling as
though I feel as though this is him like
that's his personality like that's not
my personality right so like for him he
might not have thought much of it
um however no I mean he didn't ask again
like but I also like I responded and I
was like I I think I was like you two or
something yeah I'm not gonna be a [ __ ]
but I was it wasn't like does he know
about this natural podcast like do you
ever get nervous that people you go on
dates with I actually hope he listens so
I hope he learned something no sometimes
you know to hear someone's like unbiased
POV of like your person alley it can be
quite jarring but sometimes it's what
you need it's the kick in the ass yeah
no totally and I talk about dating a lot
on the snatchler like my like
experiences and just like how guys are
but like if it's something that like I'm
actually seeing or like that we're going
like on multiple days like I don't say a
word yeah no of course not like that's
terrible and so how do you explain to
people what you do for a living on a
date so easy because I have a corporate
job so you just talk about that yeah
that's smart and then it's like and then
eventually if we keep like seeing each
other then they look you up on Instagram
like that guy from the summer like did
you know about the snatchler
um yes and he started listening to it no
yeah that's really a problem yeah no no
yeah that's terrible yeah but I didn't I
never spoke about him so I didn't mind
oh okay and I don't really mind it
because I talk about other dates and
then if they listen and they're like oh
she's seeing other people like good put
a fire under your ass
counts the thing about counts is she's
got a plan don't underestimate the
counts no I have definitely been guilty
of underestimating the counts and she's
[ __ ] come from my neck
um thank you so much for being here
couns make sure to listen to the
snatchler if you're interested in what
it's like to be like a a gorgeous young
person because you can't find a man it's
very exciting it's very exciting to be a
gorgeous young person you're going to do
the stories with me and we're going to
do deer toasters so I think there's
really no better time than right now to
dive in are you prepared I'm prepared
for the past no
without Jackie does this part without
further ad did it did it do
here are the past five stories that you
need to know
that are brought to you by verst
Skin's complicated but skin care should
not be and that's where verse comes in
with their clean products results driven
products and drugstore prices from
ethically sourced ingredients to
recycled packaging verst products are
developed for you with you and with your
planet in mind
the verse eucalyptus cleansing bomb has
come from my neck this year I had it
before they became a sponsor because I'm
trendy like that
um I've been wearing full Glam Monday
Tuesday Wednesday today I'm gonna I have
a photo shoot full Glam and then I have
an event I swear before the verse
cleansing Mom I would have to do like
three rounds of makeup removal the verse
cleansing mom is everything of the sword
and I got this little headband from
Versa gets my hair out of my face when I
use my cleansing balm I'm a verse girly
their formulas are formulated to the
highest standards in the world they use
safe and effective ingredients at skin
changing levels think retinol and
vitamin C but it's a fraction of the
cost of high-end skin care it is of
course cruelty free vegan dermatologist
tested sensitive skin friendly it is
sustainable and sustainability is at the
heart of everything they do they use
post-consumer recycled materials in
their packaging and they maintain a net
zero climate emission so if you want to
check out verse skin go to versed
skin.com slash toast and use code toast
at checkout for 10 off your purchase
first is
v-e-r-s-e-d-s-k-i-n.com slash
toastverstskin.com toast use kotos to
check out so many of their products have
gone viral on Tick Tock and I'm really
on the pulse of all things I need that
because last night I was having such a
hard time taking off my makeup or go
cleansing bomb from burst I got you on
it's everything of the sort today's
episode is also brought to you by
Missouri so your major I love Missouri
so with the holidays approaching you're
probably building your gifting list and
Missouri believes that you don't have to
overspend to treat those you love most
they design high quality fine jewelry
that you can live in and style your own
way thing about Missouri is like yeah of
course beautiful setting and smart you
can shower with it like the fact that
it's all the jewelry that everyone wears
now is like cheap crap that like makes
your neck green majority is really high
quality and it's also really reasonably
priced so they offer in-store and
virtual styling lessons for expert
gifting and stacking advice and they
have 60 day returns during the holidays
which is nice because you know things
just things happen you know things
happen you forget to return and the next
thing you know you just check with an
item you also could guess what the
person wants wrong right right so
majority is taking care of you and your
loved ones this holiday season
um they've curated gift guides they have
something for every budget so that's
responsibly sorts Diamond Hoops recycled
14 karat solid gold earrings and they
drop new Styles every Monday so you're
guaranteed to find something unique for
everyone on your list or more
importantly and most likely treat
yourself with shiny gifts for everyone
Missouri is where wish lists come true
simplify your holiday shopping and go to
missouri.com that's m-e-j-u-r-i.com
majority.com you won't regret it because
the toast said so and everything we say
is usually correct we've never uttered
One Lie true and Missouri is great and
all the cool girls wear majority like I
see it on Instagram like Lauren
Elizabeth she introduced me like years
ago she had a collab with them it's
really just stunning high quality pieces
all right counts you ready for the past
five I'm ready first is not like a story
but just an update to like what's been
going on everyone is creaming their
pants it's really like I want to talk
about it's an interesting study yeah
hold on the sirens shut the [ __ ] up
[ __ ] like for real
okay listen
um so there's something maybe drama
which is so crazy to me because there's
no drama yet like there's all based on
like a Reddit thread yeah like claims
like so there are claims of like things
going on in their marriage claims of
things going on in her business him
embezzling and there's not been one
article yet not one article also like no
one has found as far as I know like any
sort of like document like from the
government like they say he's been
arrested there's just like no action
tangible evidence for anyone to actually
be like talking about it and like the
way that everyone is turned upside down
like is everyone just like dying for a
scandal or it's like no she's really
interesting people and and I talk about
it all the time when we discuss like
different cancellations hers is so
interesting to me because her
cancellation like she got [ __ ]
annihilated yeah for getting coveted
yeah
like March people are probably this is
going to be added to one of my favorite
stories and I never stopped talking
about but it's really interesting to me
she got covered March 4th nobody [ __ ]
knew anything like so she was living
with her life she had a cold but she's a
mom so she went to school it's like she
went to school like she didn't know like
it was this biological weather we were
going to be in lockdown for two years so
then like she just got [ __ ]
annihilated for being like irresponsible
but it was like nobody knew he didn't
know it was really she got covered both
like a week the week of lockdown yeah so
I just always find that situation really
interesting and I think the reason why
people you know bandwagon hate her so
much is because she's fabulous fabulous
she's gorgeous she's naturally thin like
yeah you want to hate her like yeah she
lives this gorgeous life her kids are
beautiful and and she's just like she
really is that [ __ ] like yeah she's
that [ __ ] she has three kids I remember
on her um like 30th birthday she posted
she's like I can't believe I have three
kids under three under when I'm 30 like
yeah and she has also a thriving
business like I'm sorry like who
wouldn't hate this [ __ ] like I hate her
yeah she's everything I want to be yeah
like a successful business kids out of
the way
um gorgeous apartment rich like yeah so
and people she gets comments like eat a
cheeseburger literally if someone said
that
I'd be like I would frame it so you
think I'm
like who honestly like who wouldn't hate
her so the fact that now people have a
thread I know and they're pulling it and
people are really exposing themselves
for being so vicious like schadenfreude
it's so crazy like and we don't even
know we have no proof that he embezzled
we have no proof that there's literally
anything going on except for people
saying [ __ ] on social media based off of
nothing so and I'm sure there is an
article coming out as of today we're
recording at 11 A.M on Thursday morning
there is no article
um so I don't know what we could
possibly speculate about the only
article I actually saw was them
categorically denying so yeah so the
rumors are that he has you know been
embezzling money from her company and
her investors and that they're having
marital problems a spokesperson for
something Navy company
said categorically untrue Brennan
chartis doesn't even have access to
company funds he couldn't possibly he's
not an employee he couldn't possibly
embezzle because I don't know how he
would get his hands on the bank account
yeah and then a rep for Ariel privately
responded to the post saying they're
very happily married and then the update
that I was going to share is as of this
morning she shared a selfie of them
saying coffee date now I want to say how
much of a sleigh her handling this is
like I love that the internet has their
bragas in a Twist yeah and home girls
over here unbothered in her Chanel rain
boots and her iced coffee date with her
husband and the world has turned itself
upside down and she's playing with them
and I'm kind of obsessed no and like I
don't want to give us credit for
anything but I just have a feeling like
this were happening to us like we would
do the same thing I don't know I don't
really handle public Scandal well like
but we wouldn't let you do anything no I
know you guys are good but like for me
I'm like I have to be checked into an
institution immediately like I'm not you
and then wouldn't be composting coffee
no no I'm I I'm not okay when that [ __ ]
happened so like I have so much respect
yes and I feel like that that sort of
not give a [ __ ] energy comes from like
being a mom like that's her priority a
thousand percent but also like this
ain't her first rodeo no I know and I
feel like she handled her coveted thing
like I would handle it like she was like
Panic yeah and you learn from that you
learn from that so until we have
something to talk about like I don't
know what else we could say yeah besides
speculating which doesn't help anyone no
for me I think a lot of people like the
most interesting parts of this is like
digging into Ariel's like life and her
family and her money for me I think
what's been most interesting is the way
people on the internet yeah are clearly
like
vicious when it comes to certain people
yes and I don't know what Ariel charnis
has done to give people a reason to
despise her in the way that they do but
like did I miss the part where she
killed him on no right so I was sending
you tick tocks that like were really so
mean I mean and also
like it's one thing to think things like
that are like eat like I've had like
crazy oh girl nobody has more evil
thoughts than me like I'm literally the
nastiest [ __ ] you'll ever meet but it's
another thing to pick up your phone
verbalize it record it you saying it and
post it to the internet everyone to see
this The Tick Tock that I was referring
to that I saw and I sent it to I was
like holy [ __ ] this [ __ ] evil evil
because as far what everyone thinks is
that her husband was embezzling money
from her company we have no proof of
that and the company has denied it
um and that Arielle had absolutely no
idea
so Ariel in this hypothetical story that
hasn't even come out yet Ariel's not
even the villain she's really a victim
of her husband's but that alleged
infidelity and alleged embezzlement but
then people are like no she definitely
knew like but why so this Tick Tock is
like I want to see Arielle charnis sell
every item she owns and I want the
paparazzi to record her going down to
Saks Fifth Avenue and returning all of
her belongings and I want her to record
it and post it I'm like Jesus Christ
calm down like there is this General
sentiment especially on the internet of
like
if you're rich we hate you 100 whether
you're a good person or not like we just
hate you so I I get that that's where I
think a lot of it stems from is it all
stems from jealousy is her being really
successful financially in her business
and then also her family and her
husband's family being very wealthy like
people on the internet internet culture
like you just hate rich people so I get
it to a point because I am to my core
like an Internet troll like I am I get
it but I'm also a human being and this
is like a family with three young kids
and like again no article has come out
so it's like we're all get and I just
feel like when this article comes out
like it's gonna be maybe like because we
built it up so much like it's nothing
Burger yeah because they've denied and I
do kind of believe that
Brandon did not is his name Brandon or
Brendan I don't know is her name Ariel
or Arya like I cannot pronounce I think
it's
Arielle charnis and Brandon and Brandon
Ariel and Brandon
um okay but I do I do believe that like
he was not embezzling because it's not
so easy to embezzle he's not an employee
of the company he has his own company if
he was embezzling money from his own
company that is entirely possible but I
don't understand how like that would be
like bed embezzling money from the toast
like you can't [ __ ] like you don't even
have the credit card yeah so I'm just
curious like and yeah if it is true like
I want no Logistics
so maybe the article comes out today or
tomorrow and I'll be wrong but I'd say
that they're dragging their feet on the
article I know wow and so Jamal said on
the episode yesterday that like they're
dragging their feet on the article
because the article the concept of the
article got leaked and now people are
coming forward
so you think they're building there's
more research to do because now people
know the article's coming out and
because Dumas was saying I got a million
DMS and I'm not even a journalist from
people like in New York who know them
who had things to say but like are they
just talking about like gossip yeah
right I don't know right because there's
an element of here that's just gossip
like you know marital problems which
really is none of our business and then
there's an element of like criminal
right and so people saying he got
arrested in Miami two nights ago he was
at the polar bar got arrested
um no I didn't no we didn't like I
literally
I can't say what I like somebody saw him
just he's not okay someone I know saw
him like literally
he's not
so and also if he was arrested there
would be some sort of record obviously
and you know those internet trolls they
went to you know Miami-Dade Police
report.com and if it was a mug shot or
like a record yeah it would be it would
be posted on TMZ like so I just oh and
then
allegedly yesterday there was this thing
that came out that said Arielle had sent
a letter a note to her subscribers on um
like her something Navy email list or
whatever and it was this long thing
about you know there's been a lot of
allegations about my husband I'm gonna
be keeping this private protecting my
girls I actually thought it was a very
well well written statement it was a
very well written statement if Brandon
did something wrong because it was a
very well written statement if Ariel
wrote it right it was somebody on some
freak a mother this the people on the
internet are really showing themselves
to be psychotic somebody fake released a
statement on Ariel's behalf
people are not [ __ ] okay the article
hasn't even come out yet I know everyone
really needs to take a step back once
the article comes out we can all wild
out as much as we [ __ ] want yeah but
until then calm the [ __ ] down we are not
okay we're not okay
and this is just like a story that I
think people are like getting excited
about
and you know me I get excited about
stuff I'm just not maybe it's because
she's like a Jewish girl in the city and
like I on some level relate to her like
I just I've met her a few times I really
don't know her people oh I met her I met
her and Brandon too in the Hamptons and
I was like I went after I was like hi
like I'm Claudia they literally couldn't
have been nicer she came up to me at
dinner um and I think a lot of the girls
who work for her toasters and she was
like she knows like one of my favorite
stories is defending her covid thing
because I don't feel like she did
anything wrong and she was like thank
you so much
um and she couldn't have been Kinder and
she was like all the girls in my office
read your book and they were like
reading me passages she could not have
been nicer so maybe that's why I feel
but also I think
we're also like empathetic no but I I I
do often come on this show Jackie too
like in defensive influencers I think
yeah exactly it's such a bad rap and the
way people are acting like this like
she's an A-list celebrity she's not no
she's an influencer with you know with
three kids and and no full-time security
like like celebrities do like we need to
calm down so I think that's my where my
empathetic approach from comes from
because I don't have an empath approach
with everyone like I'm I'm gonna get in
and conspiracy theorize with the best of
them yeah but this I don't know why I'm
not getting maybe it's because I've met
her and she's been really lovely but
also because I on some level I feel
similar to her she's like a colleague
she's a New York City influencer
um and she's a mom I don't know I I'm
not like dancing for her demise yeah
yeah no but you know and I don't do this
on purpose but like I somehow find
myself at the middle of like all these
controversies somehow no I swear okay
because
the Reddit thread that like blew up and
I just want to say like I didn't look I
haven't I have read some of the most
factually incorrect things about myself
and you
on Reddit okay don't tell me that you
told me what like people making stuff up
about us oh you know what I'm talking
about I have no idea recently
on Reddit a story about you oh oh okay
oh I have read some
straight up [ __ ] lies yeah yeah so
I'm not inclined to believe something
because it's on Reddit but the thread
that like went viral and started this
whole thing somebody was like wait on
the toast last week Claudia ashrae said
she heard the craziest thing about a New
York City influencer
and that we'd soon find out that's not
what I said I said I heard the craziest
thing about a New York City influencer
and I can't say it but it was a craziest
[ __ ] thing it was not about about
Ariel charnis I do see how someone could
think that but it wasn't and I didn't
say that that people would soon find out
I just heard something about like the
way someone behaved and it was the
craziest thing I told you yeah it was
the craziest thing I'd ever heard and I
just like wanted to be Gossip Girl and
like make stuff up on the toes but it
wasn't this I I really I don't know I
know what everyone else knows I didn't
find out about this until like until
everyone else yeah no apparently this
had been brewing and then like yeah no I
don't [ __ ] at the fan I don't like troll
you know threads like that because
um I love myself and well not even just
that like I have to eat I have to
protect my Peas I have a life and that
too
um so I just let's all be conscious of
what we're reading like but just because
it's on red once it's in an article even
though I still think an article can be
wrong yellow journalism right but once
it's in an article it has way more
believability these are just random
Anonymous people
on social media literally we must be
cautious you guys use
your monocle okay look question every
grain of salt grain of salt until
there's an article but even then but
even then I know because I've had some
really [ __ ]
libelist articles written about me and
I'll say that and I'll leave it at that
so that's why I think that's why my own
experience
also contributes to me being more
empathetic from this storyline and not
being like yes let's ruin it and let's
you know like
Hocus Pocus right you know
so I guess like maybe like tomorrow's
episode and if the article drops while
we're sitting here lizard you know just
to
just to wave a white flag
um because that would be embarrassing
I'm like all over here like yeah yeah
um
but that was our first story okay what's
next hit me it's really sad counts it's
about one of our favorite girls
yeah Celine Dion has been diagnosed with
stiff person syndrome it's a
neurological disorder and she's canceled
her European tour again
Celine Dion announced on Thursday
morning that she has been diagnosed with
stiff person syndrome and will be
postponing or canceling her shows here's
what she said in a video that was posted
to social media a teary-eyed video
I've been dealing with problems with my
health for a long time and it's been
really difficult for me to face these
challenges and talk about everything
that I've been going through recently
I've been diagnosed with a very rare
neurological syndrome which affects
something like one in a million people
she continued explaining that this is
the condition that has been causing all
of the spasms she's been having
stiff person Syndrome causes rigidity
and spasms in the trunk and limbs
according to the Cleveland Clinic over
time leg muscles become stiff followed
by other muscles including arms and face
the Power of Love singers 54 said that
the condition has made it difficult to
walk and has prevented her from singing
the way that she's used to all I know is
singing she said it's what I've done
almost all my life and it's what I love
to do the most she concluded her video
by saying she will not be ready to
restart her European tour in February
it's been a struggle she said she hopes
of recovery with the help of ongoing
treatment now this is so sad but like
she ever gonna be able to tour again
that's the vibe I'm getting and that was
like the energy she was putting out like
it was almost final how old is she she's
54. she's
if you saw her perform you would think
she was 44. yeah she's
endlessly energized she sings she dances
she just she's wild she does comedy like
yeah she's really a jack of all trades I
feel like if you're a fan and you've
been following this is like the third
time she's postponed this one specific
tour and at first we were like okay A
little coven maybe right then it was
just like
there were rumors
and now it turns out like there was
something going on and at this time I'm
thinking of Brian Kelly Same I was gonna
put it in the chat today but I was like
you know what no no he sent in my chat
with me him and John and he sent like a
whole like lengthy um explanation of
what this disease is and he was like
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] three times [ __ ] I was
like are you okay he's like no
he is Celine Dion's number one fan a
thousand percent and this is really hard
for him so obviously I'm taking this
tough but like I'm thinking of my dear
friend I'm thinking my dear friend and
honestly all the gays around the world
because I think this is going to be
particularly tough for the community I
agree that's really really upsetting I
know because it did it did feel like
kind of final like the energy she was
putting forth in the video like I didn't
watch the video but I read the article
what to do yeah I mean there's nothing
she can't and it's incurable well it's
like a very rare I don't think it's one
of these things that there's like a
million cures right right it's very rare
it said one in a million people
that's crazy odd no I know and if you
know what's so crazy is because the last
time I saw her actually saw her the week
that something Navy got code but I got
her the week but I saw her at Barclay
Center the week of covid
um and you would never you would think
she had the energy of a 25 year old like
yeah so this is someone who's clearly an
amazing physical health I mean it takes
priorities insane her body's insane she
prioritizes like her health and wellness
because you can't be 55 running around
like that if you're not constantly
working out and so this is someone who's
obviously prioritized health and still
ends up with this faccocked right so
like that just no drinking eat the donut
yeah I had two Donuts yesterday I was
somebody sent me donuts oh somebody's
Uncle Donuts send me donuts um do they
send them like as a congratulations they
send them into congratulations and then
I guess I forgot like a week ago I was
talking about how like I wanted one of
those sprinkly little [ __ ] so badly
and they sent me them to like
congratulate me on the end of tour they
sent me two dozen that's so nice they
sent me Munchkins and a box of joe the
box of joe is so good to Ben drink it it
was a field day for the staff in my
building because I gave them everything
I'm not gonna eat two dozen donuts a box
of munchkins I don't even drink coffee
so I gave them all but one box of donuts
yeah and then me my housekeeper had a
field day we just really went ham like
on the donuts
um
and then when I got home from the tpg
awards last night I hadn't had dinner so
I had another donut but I am starving
but I got I was so hungry tell me if
this is okay I had I had ordered pizza
maybe about three weeks ago and I
finally arrived no
and I put it in the freezer
okay and then I had a slice last night I
think that's fine how did you heat it up
microwave yeah it's like kind of gross
but it's also still like a little icy ew
I think it's totally fine okay my
stomach feels fine this morning no I
think it's fine frozen food like it's
fine you know that actually is begs the
question that I've been dealing with I
got a pie another congratulatory I got a
Casey pie Sam Frankel dropped it off her
sister makes the best pies best pies and
like I'm not gonna eat it right now so
should I freeze it yeah of course okay
it's still sitting out how long has it
been out since yesterday okay that's
fine I'm like so worried about this pie
now you have to put you have to put in
it's the best pie yeah but also maybe I
should just eat it yeah what are you
waiting for like this has been like a
like it's not a good week for me I'm not
gonna drop any weight you know I feel
bad it's been it's almost celebrating
yeah it's holidays what are you waiting
for what are you waiting for so you
wanna change the world classic 90s what
is that from what song is that it's it's
from every okay wait actually I know
it's from the scene in like a classic
early 2000s kids movie where they kiss
so you want wanna change the world what
are you waiting for so you wanna start
right now sleepover what are you waiting
for now hold on hold the [ __ ] on okay
this is where you need the app where you
just sing It's called Shazam so you want
to change the world what are you waiting
for movie soundtrack
oh interesting movie soundtrack oh my
God they're giving me Waiting on the
World to Change
[ __ ] okay wait no
so you want to change the world what are
you waiting for so you want to start
right now what are you waiting for yeah
just look up the lyrics get the name of
the song right
oh my God what it's sung by Lindsay
Lohan oh until she kisses um Freaky
Friday
maybe Freaky Friday because it's
definitely not a mean girl commissions
of a Teenage Drama Queen when she kids
when she kisses um the guy who fixes
cars
oh yeah oh what a song what a moment
what a film what a film I didn't mean
what a song I meant to say what a film
speaking of what a film everyone's
talking about the film in our next story
which is brought to you by Bruce Bruce
ain't nothing better than a Bruce let me
just get my little uh phone ready sorry
everyone sorry everyone sorry everyone
Grandma alert Grandma alert okay ready
Grandma alert is brought to you by Bruce
an electric toothbrush that will change
the way you think about brushing your
teeth with powerful Sonic technology
Ultra Gentle bristles the brush
redefines what it means to have super
clean teeth it's like that feeling when
you just leave the dentist a fresh whole
mouth clean every single day and get 20
off when you pick up your brush brush
kit and the plan when you go to
brush.com toast that's 20 off when you
go to
bruush.com toast the brush kit includes
the electric toothbrush three brush
heads a magnetic charging station and a
Sleek travel case using industry-leading
Sonic technology to produce 42 000 brush
Strokes per minute which is 300 times
brush Strokes per minute this helps with
deep cleaning in those hard to reach
places I love the brush because I'm lazy
enough to do anything I just put it in
my mouth and it does all the work for me
the battery life lasts four weeks so I
can take it with me when I travel I
don't have to leave the charging station
on my countertop and it's just stunning
I got one for Ben he's got like a hunter
green one I got like a millennial pink
we're really reinforcing gender
stereotypes with our colors and it's
fabulous you have a brush I don't have
it you don't no well you've got to go to
bruce.com toast to get 20 off at
bruce.com toast brush is spelled
b-r-u-u-s-h.com and when you sign load
time when you sign up and download them
when you sign up for the brush kit and
plan you'll get the three brush heads
the electric toothbrush the magnetic
charging station and the Sleek travel
case everything you could possibly need
to have a pearly white year-round thank
you Bruce for sponsoring today's episode
that's bruce.com toast all right next
story everyone is talking about
Prince Harry and Meghan markle's
documentary now I haven't seen it so I
don't feel like I wanted to do like
number one story bombshell yeah but I
did think it was interesting that we
finally found out how they met
oh did we not know I thought they were
introduced I had thought that they were
introduced by Pierce Morgan or no she
had went to dinner and drinks with
Pierce Morgan the day of their date
first date
I don't know there was definitely
something well it turns out that they
met on Instagram so page six says it's a
love story for the digital age and when
I went to choose stories for today there
must have been 15 on the home page
things from the article things from the
documentary articles from the
documentary so they revealed their
romance started thanks to the power of
social media in their Netflix docu
series Harry and Megan which was
released today the Duke and Duchess of
Sussex explained how the relationship
came about in the summer of 2016. wow
it's already been so long I was
scrolling through my feed and one of my
friend and one of my friends and someone
who was a friend had this video of the
two of them like a Snapchat wait this
makes no [ __ ] sense this is what
Harry says
I was scrolling through my feed and one
of my friends and someone who was a
friend had this video of the two of them
so I guess Megan and this person it's
like a Snapchat video after seeing the
snap of Marco with a dog filter the
British Prince was curious to know more
I was like who is that he shared and
here they have the video in question
she's using the classic 2016 dog
Marco said her friend later told her
that the prince has was interested in
meeting her but the nickname didn't ring
a bell for the American actress I said
who is that
I asked if I could see his feed that to
me was the best barometer so I went
through and it was just through this
beautiful photography and all these
environmental shots and this time he was
spending in Africa
I feel like they're talking really weird
whatever pleased with his feed the pair
exchanged phone numbers the very next
day kicking off a royal love story and
Harry said the pair were constantly in
touch from then on even though Markle
initially wanted to be free and enjoy
the summer as a single woman according
to her friend Lindsay Jill Roth Marco
had planned A Single Girl Summer and she
had a lot of plans to go around Europe
another friend Lucy Frazier added in the
docu-series even Marcola herself
confirmed that she was really intent on
being single and just having a fun girl
time we just pause for a sec yeah I
don't know one girl who sure you can go
into the summer wanting a single girl
summer but if a prince second heir to
the throne or whatever he is is trying
to pursue you like you just throw that
single girl
but like you real like the second you
realize that they're interested like oh
murder that's exactly what she did she
said it was supposed to be a single girl
summer but like I gave him my number and
we didn't stop texting her no it sounds
like she really tried to do the single
summer no no no no no no they literally
said she was supposed to but nah like
literally relatable that's exactly what
you would do Margo that's what I was
saying no I know
um so you and Meghan Markle have a lot
in common that's what I'm saying we both
like suits so then they got engaged yada
yada we know
um but she said I had a career I had my
life I had my path and then Along Came H
that's what she calls him talk about a
plot twist
so I want to talk about for me the most
interesting part cool they didn't meet
on Instagram that's very misleading like
he saw a picture of her for the first
time on Instagram which is just a
consequence of being alive in this day
and age
um but I think it's really interesting
that she calls him H that's I actually
think it's beyond cringe when people
call anyone
like the letter like it's Gossip Girl oh
okay b s so I I hate it if anyone call
me m c don't no I agree but I also hate
when girls like
okay let's say everyone on the planet
called Ben
sulfur yeah like some of his friends do
but it's not like his go-to nickname and
like literally his name was offer you
know like
I'm trying to think of like a person I
know who oh okay like for some reason
one of Ben's really really good friends
from high school they call him Looch
okay same as Michael but I don't know
I've never called him my game my life
his name is Luke that would be like so
if he started dating someone and then
she's like Michael Michael by the way I
hate when girls all girls do that I like
I have that in mind also yeah especially
like I'm not naming names because like I
hate him but like someone that I used to
date everyone called them by their last
name by his last name okay I'm trying to
think of who you know who okay and then
like the like his subsequent girlfriends
I think I did it too like called him by
his first name oh my God I just like
call the person what everyone calls them
I hate when girls are like that would be
like me calling Benjamin yeah no that's
and like the full name no it's like
calling Ben Benjamin and everyone calls
him Ben no like he says why just like
for what to like prove you're different
like we get it we're not [ __ ] him you
are but like you can call him back
that's exactly what it is no it's like
marking your territory I hate when girls
do that like
I'm trying to think of like a perfect
example like it's really like Ben
Benjamin yeah Ben Benjamin or like if
everybody calls someone a nickname and
then like the girlfriend does and it's
like why we get it you're not like us
you're different you're on a different
level you're closer with him like you're
[ __ ] him we don't care right I hate
so the H doesn't bother me the H is
cringe for sure it's giving Gossip Girl
Like H whenever I see it anywhere like
if it's like someone like it's their
anniversary and someone's like I love
you baby yeah I completely agree except
for my friend Beatrice we call her B but
it's not letter b e a b-e-a totally
totally it's a nickname for Beatrice
yeah different yeah the letter is cringe
and then when people say like that would
be like if she called him Harold if
that's not his name you know what I mean
or whatever but like that wouldn't even
be as bad Harold no it would like I hate
when girls do like the full name it's
like stop no I get it I do you get why
they do it no no I get why that's
bothersome to me yes okay so you're
defending me I'm on your side okay it's
so hard to know with you you're always
attacking me that's
Kettle pot black
well I haven't watched a documentary yet
so
and there's part two so maybe I'll just
recap it in full but what I've heard is
that it was not nearly as damaging as a
lot of people thought to them to the
royal family it's really like their
version of events
with very little I did see like a clip
where she I'm trying not to watch Clips
but there's so many on Tick Tock yeah
where she said like she's just like a
very warm American and she's a hugger
yeah and like the formality of the royal
family publicly is the same energy they
have privately they're still very formal
they're British
I think that's like an accurate
description of like probably how they
immediately like got off on the wrong I
also feel like that's any like American
in London UK like I feel like all
they're all very like none of them are
super Huggy so like if we were to go in
with like our you know like big tits big
tits like Yay like I think everyone
would be like oh my God they talked
about that in downtown a lot since Cora
was American and whenever she would be
even remotely sentimental they'd be like
don't be some American mother yeah
exactly so it's just a different
cultural thing so I think that was a
pretty accurate
reaction from them
um next story is a little Instagram news
Pete Davidson has officially returned to
Instagram in the most bizarre way ever
um he's laying in bed he's looking
actually really cute he looked like five
years old yes okay because he finally
got rid of the platinum hair and when he
goes back and forth between the Platinum
the Platinum is not a good look for him
no and I didn't realize it until he put
up this video of him just like in his
house with his brown hair and he looked
like he was 17 100 and he's laying in
bed with Eli Manning yeah so I don't
know where we go from here his his
account name is it's a joint account
with Eli Pete underscore Eli 10. they've
started an Instagram account together
that's interesting he said hello
Instagram I've decided to come back but
only with the goat Eli Manning is lying
next to bed next to Pete in bed and then
he says what's up your bed is so
comfortable and then he responds all
things we've been having a good time on
my bed stay tuned for more photos on the
gram
it was like obviously satirical yeah let
me tell you like Eli Manning is so hot
oh so hot and like I'm actually okay so
you're a young person yeah you're single
yes honestly I feel like
I could see a world in which like you're
spotted out with Pete Davidson because
you're like yeah I would like love so my
question for you was like do you think
he's cute I do I don't I do I think he's
like got like like Swag like for sure
if I if he was like not Pete Davidson
and he was like a random man on the
street you know he was like had you know
a job at like a like a law firm yeah
like and I imagine if I saw him like on
a dating app like I don't know how I
would swipe you would probably swipe
right because he was like tall and like
if he was Jewish yeah yeah he met your
criteria right and like had a good job
like yeah yeah totally but definitely
swipe right yes but the fame helps and
also just like his like energy like so
it's like I watch that video and I was
like damn Eli Manning is hot like that
was my takeaway I think they're both hot
there's room for everybody no for sure
but looks like I feel like nobody
watched that video and even looked at
Eli Manning they're like put the camera
back on Pete that's fair and I was
sitting here being like that's also
supposed to be like get nothing from
Pete so like once you get like a little
bit I know I'm just like kind of over it
I know um I feel exhausted by the Pete
Davidson and the dating of it all like I
can't tell you how much I actually don't
care about him in emrata no but it's
like so cliche and it's so obvious like
oh two like amazingly famous gorgeous
people knowing like how many times has
he done that I know like find somebody
like an ugly girl okay please
just so we I can feel like you know
close to you yeah I agree I'm just gonna
go over it so I don't really care I know
I kind of agree too I was like after the
relevancy that you get in dating Kim
Kardashian like nothing's gonna match
that so and no one you date after is
ever gonna top it so like the interest
is just not it's just lacking no it's
true like even after Ari I was like
where can he go from here and he still
did like Kim totally topped it and he
would have to say [ __ ] Taylor Swift
like
I mean it's not happening but you know
no or
um Giselle yeah okay yeah and I want Kim
to date Tom I know saying it's working
it's working
um our favorite final story is another
you know it's that time of year we're
getting yearly Recaps Google has
released their top searches of 2022. oh
I love it and a bunch of Pop Culture
moments made the made the list so the
most searched events Queen Elizabeth's
death was obviously
um up there
uh the election Ukraine the Powerball
numbers
okay that makes sense I love the
Powerball numbers yeah I know you do um
Will Smith was that 2022 that's my my
reaction was the same same with Johnny
Depp that was on the list too for most
top searched events that feels Johnny
Depp feels 2022. it feels like another
lifetime especially the Oscars thing
yeah especially because like this week
on the toast we were talking about the
upcoming Oscars so it's like enough oh I
guess like those were probably
technically the big moments of Pop
Culture guess what the most searched
movie was
don't worry darling no no did it even
make the list no wait wait wait I feel
like I know you have to think about like
not like think about movies that like
Top Gun Top Gun is number three
oh what was bigger than Top Gun think
about
like Marvel [ __ ] kaler
oh
um
oh I'm thinking
Encanto yes okay number one two Thor oh
three Top Gun okay that makes it for the
Batman yeah and then the bunch like you
know random random what about
celebrities most searched TV shows okay
I have to think about this number one
is it a Netflix show no is it like cable
yes
do I watch it I'll give you a clue I
think so you dumb [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm
gonna [ __ ] you up Euphoria yep that is
not cable that's HBO
oh I guess it goes I'm streaming service
okay like I don't know is HBO cable um
like I watched it on my cable box like
can you go to like the HBO channel and
watch it when it comes out no of course
it premieres there um I just watched on
HBO Max no I guess that's so true but
like it's on TV okay all right um number
two stranger things okay three is that
show The Watcher
which only recently came out which is
kind of crazy I didn't watch it me
neither inventing Anna okay House of the
Dragon
I'm shocked House of the Dragon is so
low okay wait Moon night I don't know
what that is seven Yellowstone love wait
where are you at oh my God I I've had
the busiest week of my life so I haven't
made a lot of progress but last night I
watched one episode and it was like a
pretty terrible episode it was like an
episode where everyone goes camping so
no one's at the ranch and they're just
whatever it's like boring and it's like
it also takes course over one night yeah
but the most amazing thing happened and
it made the whole thing worth it
um because Beth and rip find themselves
alone at the ranch and they're like
what's something like we can do that
we've wanted to do at the ranch that
we've never been able to do because
we've never been alone and
um rip turns the lights on and the music
on and him and um Beth dance in the
horse thing to Lady May by Tyler
Childers
and let me tell you how Tyler Childers
okay I've been dragged to filth on the
show for saying Tyler Childers it's
children this is the first time I've
actually said it correctly so it's
children sorry
um the way Chris stapleton's music and
Chris Childers child Tyler Childers
music like have Yellowstone in a
Chokehold and it comes on at the perfect
time so like him and Beth are dancing in
the middle of the night to this song I
was like sobbing no Yellowstone has such
a good soundtrack I like Shazam so many
they have this one band that I found
called Shane and Shane So Random so good
well
um but yeah they love a Tyler Childers
and Tim McGraw also wrote a song for
Yellowstone oh it's just it's really
it's the vibe no it's actually amazing
okay I'm so [ __ ] glad you're here
like no I know and that you don't listen
to the toast because you don't support
me but you would know
that's a really good question that's no
that's totally fair too yeah um one of
the recurring themes on this show is
like I'm so stubborn I mean hi no yeah
you're definitely worse because I can at
least acknowledge like
like when I'm being stubborn I know I'm
being stubborn I'm not gonna justify I'm
just being like so Jackie's like
Yellowstone I'm like no I'm on the mood
I'm just whatever yeah and so seeing me
Downton Abbey same with reading you know
like I'm just a few years delayed you
know it's fine
um do you know what the most searched
songs were
and think back to
the most searched movie
the most so Encanto
we don't talk about burnout yeah number
one was her song wow that's crazy yeah
um
jiggle jiggle and jiggle jiggle it folds
it's crazy how this like whole thing
Tick Tock because on this list is also
Unholy wow already I know which is a
song that came out a month ago and it's
not that good but also he started
teasing it in June yeah
um running up that hill by Kate Bush
which is a song from the 90s yeah crazy
um
about damn time lizzo and to Hero Taylor
Swift yada yada
um there isn't a list for most searched
there is oh no
for most searched people ready okay
Johnny Depp is number one wow Will Smith
is number two makes sense Amber Heard is
number three okay Antonio Brown I think
there was like a football drama I'm not
familiar with it
um Carrie Lake I think she's a
politician and a sarokan delvey Chris
Rock
Andrew Tate
are you familiar of course because Tick
Tock yeah
um I thought that was interesting Adam
Levine
oh yeah and then Serena Williams when I
feel oh she's retired yeah and remember
her U.S open run yeah Kendall was going
in her Bottega earrings yeah yeah yeah
it's open because most of these people
went through like a thing yeah of course
they're not like random
selections so then I forgot about Serena
Williams retirement
um and then the most popular churches
overall the number one most search of
all time this year
has it been said no and I'll give you a
clue it's like something we all were
obsessed with for five minutes
I like can't remember things so I'm not
gonna be able to answer this quickly
okay but like think
anyone people at home to guess I need
him some people still do it but it was
like a thing on our phones that we were
obsessed with all tomorrow yes okay
then the election results okay then
Betty White oh okay but that was in
December and then Queen Elizabeth
okay well I'm in defense between
Elizabeth Betty White died last December
so there's more time for people to
search true
um Ukraine Mega Millions powerball's
number Powerball numbers and hash
who's that she is a celebrity
car accident yeah I actually just saw an
article about her recently and then
Jeffrey Dahmer because obviously that I
never watched but yes
um so those were the top Google searches
and I feel like honestly I couldn't have
guessed it like me neither a lot of it
just like doesn't apply to like me and
my interest right but not everything's
about me no that's what's a really kind
of hard thing about like growing up you
learn like actually nothing's about you
NADA and I'm not interested in a world
that's not about me so counts did I do a
good job like tailoring stories to your
desires yeah I think so okay I think so
too I felt like your energy was like
really like you were excited okay I
thought you're gonna say that like I did
a bad job like no you're doing amazing
sweetie yeah and you're not done because
we need you to advise us counts we have
some toasters going through some things
and I know you're a dog mom and there's
a dog story in here that I think is
poses a really interesting moral dilemma
so we're gonna get into Deer toasters
which is our weekly advice segment we
usually do it on Wednesdays but Jackie
had dumwa yesterday then we were going
to do it today but Jackie's out and you
know I'm just doing it do it um dear
toasters gmail.com is the email account
you can use to write in if you want some
advice from two mentally stable Queens
dear toaster is brought to you by ZocDoc
a free app that shows you doctors who
are patient reviewed take your insurance
and are available when you need them so
on stockdoc you can find every
specialist Under the Sun whether you're
trying to straighten your teeth fix your
achy back get your mold checked out or
removed Sock Doc has you covered zocdocs
mobile app is as easy as ordering a ride
to a restaurant
or getting delivery to your house you
search find in book doctors within a few
Taps find and review local doctors you
can read verified patient reviews from
real people who made real appointments
now when you walk into your doctor's
office you are all set to see someone in
your network who gets you so a lot of
like the awkward human interaction that
is involved in making doctor's
appointments is relieved with ZocDoc you
don't have to call me like you need the
insurance like do you need to blame it
just do it all on ZocDoc so you can go
to the doctor and like talk to as few
people as possible before you talk to
the doctor right it's really efficient
if you just moved it's a great way to
find new doctors when I travel I'm
always having like mysterious ailments
and zoc talk has been really helpful to
like find someone close to where I am
who takes my insurance
it's really helpful and that's why every
month millions of people use ZocDoc I am
one of them it is our go-to whenever we
need to find and book a quality doctor
especially with Jackie just having moved
she doesn't have like her go-to dentist
dermatologist elastic surgeon you didn't
hear it from gynecologists yeah all the
things so ZocDoc is really really
helpful for someone who's just moved go
to zocdoc.com toast and download the
ZocDoc app for free then start your
search for a top-rated doctor today many
are available within 24 hours that's
zocdoc.com toast
zocdoc.com
toast today's dear toasters is also
brought to you by a new favorite here at
the toast the perfect bar don't go nuts
this holiday season fuel yourself with
perfect bar the original refrigerated
protein bar that is a cookie dough
texture and a creamy and full of flavor
unlike any other bars out there now they
come in snack size which is packed up to
six grams of proteins and 150 calories
where a little goes a long way so if
you're just like running to the airport
if you're a busy Mom throw it in your
purse and it'll just like fuel you for
the day and what I love about perfect
bar um is that they are put in the
fridge so I didn't even realize how kind
of gross it is that protein bars are
like not in the fridge
um how fresh can they be not that fresh
but perfect bar is very fresh they're
made with whole food ingredients they
contain no artificial preservatives and
they are stored in the fridge so grab
one after a workout or for a quick bite
while you're out holiday shopping so you
can feel good about what you're snacking
on of course they are non-GMO project
verified they are gluten free they are
soy free they are Kosher Shalom and low
GI perfect bar knows that it will be
Love At First Bite so for a limited time
they're offering you a chance to try
their refrigerated protein bars for free
here's how it works sign up for email or
text upload a picture of your receipt
from your local grocery store and they
will reimburse you for the cost of one
bar it'll go directly into your venmo or
your PayPal account which is pretty cool
it's pretty cool all you have to do is
go to perfect snacks.com toast to get a
free perfect bar today that's perfect
snacks.com toast to get a free perfect
bar today happy snacking
here we go hey girlies I'm a new patreon
member here so thanks Girling my
boyfriend and I have been together for
three years now and have lived together
for almost a year it's the first year we
were spending the holidays together with
each other's families we just spent
Thanksgiving with his family and now we
will be spending Christmas with my
family about six months ago he started
bringing up that he wanted a nose
piercing he'll mention it every so often
and ask for my opinion I've been honest
and I've told him that I don't really
find nose piercings attractive and that
if he did get it I would at least ask
him to take it out around my super
traditional family there fast forward to
right now he's insisting that he has to
get the nose piercing this month while
there's a sale and it's become a huge
fight between us am I being a brat for
being upset that he would deliberately
go to the piercing right before seeing
my family when he knows that the
piercing would be too fresh to remove
his argument is that he's upset because
even if he gets it later on I'm gonna
make him hide it for my family for about
six months but honestly I'm just hoping
he hates it and takes it out prematurely
on his own thank you so much honestly
the thing with this is like
if I wanted to get a nose piercing like
Ben has absolutely no say true if Ben
wanted to get a nose piercing like
that's a family decision I agree so
you're totally like justified in having
an opinion on the situation and the fact
that you don't even want him to get it
but you're happy to let him get it but
only just taking it out around your
family just to avoid any unnecessary
you're not hiding who he is you're just
avoiding like unnecessary torch he's
being a baby I couldn't agree more like
you not even putting your foot down like
saying you can't get it like that is so
big of you so like the least
relationships I've heard are all about
are all about
compromise yeah
so you're letting him get it he can at
least do you a solid and not create
animosity over the holidays for you and
wait a month no you're right and like he
will hate it like he will I have faith
I'm praying for you too but even if he
doesn't he can still wait three weeks
you're not being a brat at all like
honestly why does he have to get it this
month how much is the sale going to be
also like he knows that he knows that
it's gonna bother you and bother your
family so why make your life harder like
he should be making your life easier
we're like why is he gonna go out of his
way to make your life more difficult and
put you in like a bad spot a thousand
percent you know this is like not good
boyfriend material I need to start
acting right maybe you should play this
episode for him maybe
are those easy
this one is crazy okay yeah and I I
think I know what I would do
hey Jackson Claude I love you both I
need some advice about my crunchy Angel
no while I was scrolling Instagram the
other day I saw a tagged photo of a dog
who looks just like my unique looking
dog it was such a crazy lookalike that I
clicked on the profile for more I
quickly deduced that it was my dog that
I adopted just over a year ago okay and
speaking of dog Theo has just entered
the studio come here my love come here
oh mommy loves you so oh mommy loves you
so oh you could sense we were reading a
story about one of your brethren we were
reading a story about one of your
brother and come here
oh you're gonna have to be quiet okay
this is great oh my foot's asleep [ __ ]
okay
let me go back because it's important I
quickly deduced that this was my dog
that I adopted just over a year ago the
other girl had my dog let's call him
Theo for about four months okay lost him
he was with the rescue for about two
months and I've had him for the past 14
months I adopted Theo from a totally
reputable rescue and I spent thousands
of dollars on his medical bills and
training within the first few months of
having him so I know that he's mine but
still I have a pit should I reach out to
the previous owner am I just opening up
a door that doesn't need to be I kind of
feel like if I were the other way around
I would want to know that Theo was okay
what would you do Michael does she know
the previous owner that the dog was like
found and given to this rescue no so she
just she knows nothing this her dog was
lost and so I understand wanting to give
peace of mind but also she doesn't want
to open a door and be like well this is
my dog I want him back so it's time you
know what it's time for
an anonymous letter or Ron when you Sam
when you and Ron went to bed literally a
tempered Anonymous or why can't the
current owner
go to the rescue and be like yo can you
let this woman know that you found her
dog and it's been adopted and all as
well I don't think the rescue wants to
get involved like I can understand like
them wanting to wash their hands of it
like they did their job so I understand
this girl like not wanting this other
human being like this she sounds like a
great dog mom like she trained she paid
for all the medical bills like she
sounds like she really cares so Theo is
in good hands yeah so I think it's time
for I think you need to make a fin stand
be like I'm not revealing my identity
because I don't want to open up any
doors but like I just want you to know
your dog is in amazing care I'm so sorry
that this happened the way that it did
but like I've had your dog for over a
year now possession is nine times the
law legally she totally it's her dog
yeah and also the previous owner only
had the dog for four months yeah and
like I understand that things happen but
like you're the one who lost the dog so
I was gonna say that but then I was like
is that rude I don't know like what if
that no because [ __ ] does happen you're
right no actually I'm not gonna blame
I'm not victim blaming here like it was
it things happen but it is nice that you
want to give her peace of mind but you
have to protect your piece first hundred
percent the theme of today's episode is
protecting your people it's protecting
your piece and Anonymous letter so if
you know where she lives maybe drop off
and no actually don't drop it off no no
I think a fake finsta a fake finsta or
like right send a letter in the mail but
put gloves on what the [ __ ] is she gonna
find out where she lives it's social
media it's so easy okay I think of insta
like if this happened to me I would be
so devastated
but the the nights I would spend awake
wondering if he's running through the
woods getting beaten by wolves like
you're doing her a favor so yeah yeah
yeah I think
Anonymous letter never hurt anyone okay
all right our third and final one is a
little bit longer but it it requires
attention okay you're Jackson Claude how
you doing my best friend and fellow
toaster and I are in need of some
serious advice regarding another friend
Wendy we've all been friends since we
were in preschool and have grown up
together and we are now all recently
graduated from college but we live in
different cities our friend Wendy broke
up with her long-term College boyfriend
Philip slightly unexpectedly soon after
graduating we all thought they were
going to be engaged within the year so
it came as a bit of a shock to us all
soon after the breakup news hit we come
to find that Wendy met someone Jeremy
while being a camp counselor he sparked
the reason for the breakup
why are you laughing no it's just like
the names it's funny what names people
choose yeah here's the kicker Jeremy's a
senior in high school what and she's
graduated he's at the age of consent in
a state that we live in so it's
perfectly legal but it feels a bit icky
she's been hanging out with him for
several months now and even took his
virginity
the same small private school we
attended almost five years ago and we've
told her that people are talking about
it but she doesn't really seem to care
she seems really happy with him but we
also feel like it could backfire there's
even been a few times she's talked about
missing Phillips who are really not sure
what she's thinking we obviously want
her to be happy and we want what what's
best for her but we're not sure how to
go about it personally we think Wendy
needs a reality check because this
situation feels wrong but we really
don't know what to say
sincerely two very confused toasters
that is quite the debacle so I mean it's
not even so much the years because when
you graduate college you're 21 when
you're a high school senior what you're
like 17 but okay I do want to say like
so yeah the technically the age Gap is
is fine the next five years but it's the
no but usually it's like if the place
you're at a girl's dating a guy five
years younger than her because I always
say like men have the maturity of a
two-year-old so like a 25 year old guy
and a 25 year old girl is equivalent to
a 28 year old girl and a 21 year old guy
I agree I think men are developmentally
behind about five years so that's why 20
year old girls need to date 25 year old
boys a thousand percent so she's
technically dating a 12 12 year old
I'm crying no totally it's even more
inappropriate especially he's like he's
taking SATs he's playing to college no
way it's like it's different when you're
like 40 and 35 but you're so fragile and
you're so
immature yeah
um and college is where you really grow
up a lot uh-huh so the age Gap it's not
even about the four years it's about all
the experience and the maturity it's
really [ __ ] he still lives with his
parents it's really [ __ ]
inappropriate and this girl I think
she's gross I think she's gross I think
this is hella inappropriate and I would
think it was the same a guy who just
graduated college dating a 17 year old
girl a thousand percent I think all
around this is so [ __ ] weird agreed
also it sounds like she blew up her
whole [ __ ] life because clearly she
had a really great boyfriend they were
gonna get married like and she threw it
away for a Summer Romance at Camp yes
first rule of Camp never bring it home
Camp relationships stay in Camp never
bring it home everyone knows that my God
Wendy
um that so but what do the friends do oh
right that's the people that's the
problem
um
honestly like
where are her parents yeah not to bring
them into it but no like you definitely
this is like a serious situation like
it's [ __ ] weird you have to do
something
um what's Philip up to
you know like is he doing for her you
know what because Philip deserves better
I'm not saying Philip deserves better I
hope Philip goes on to meet a lovely
Queen named Elizabeth and they live
happily ever after yeah this is
like if if Wendy was willing to throw
when he's obviously going through
something like if Wendy was willing to
throw away like a real relationship like
adult relationship a college like people
thought they were gonna engage for a
teenager like it's giving it's you know
what to reminding me of that showed the
teacher
yeah I was thinking we're like she had a
nice relationship and she like literally
like would not talk to her boyfriend
because she was like [ __ ] her student
like it was disgusting
um obviously it's not as bad as that but
it's still it's gross like I don't
and just because it's legal doesn't mean
it's right I agree I also think that the
friends like I don't know if they've had
like a conversation with her if they
have then sorry but if they haven't like
I think it's worth it to like sit her
down have a conversation voice your
concerns but then if she doesn't listen
and after that it's like there's nothing
you can do besides let it run its course
no that's what we say here at the toast
because a lot of people write in like
what do I do for my friend
um and while we all want to be good
friends and I do think you should sit
her down and like don't come at it from
like a combative way
um at some point like people's lives are
their own responsibilities and choices
they make as fully formed adults even
though like out of college like you're
not even that fully profile like this is
definitely still like her you know
making mistakes era people have to learn
things on their own yeah so you can help
someone as much as you want and you love
Wendy and you're a good friend and you
both sound like really wonderful people
you can try but then at some point we're
all on our own in this life yeah you're
on your own kid you always have been
yeah so I think you give it a go say
something once yeah and then and don't
talk so much about let bygones be
bygones I would take it from the angle
of like what's going on with you because
like there's been a lot of change and
like is there something going on in your
life because if you come out you could
be like it seems out of character yeah
if you come at it and being like you
know everyone in town is talking about
you like that's rude and that'll make
her defensive you have to be so careful
like when people when you confront
someone like it's literally an art yeah
and you can't [ __ ] it up no so good luck
with that yeah good luck with that um
keep us posted keep us posted and thank
you to everyone who wrote in to Dear
toasters again dear toasters gmail.com
this is the second to last episode of
the week I'm hoping Jackie will be back
tomorrow I think she will just this
morning was like crazy how I had to get
to the doctor and you know what but
what what I'm trying to think hold on
okay
What's the phrase but like someone's
losses are gained another but whose loss
is it in this situation Jackie's loss is
our gain yeah but like it's not even her
loss like she's literally being a mother
right [ __ ] I'm a mother no drama counts
thank you so much for being here I know
you're the busiest woman alive between
you know working a full-time job being a
full-time content creator being a
full-time podcaster
um that you would give up
like an hour and 10 minutes of your life
it means the world don't tell my boss I
will not
um
but since you're here let's make it
worth your while everyone listen to
Marco's podcast the snatchler which is
available anywhere you get your podcast
episodes drop what which day Thursdays
Thursdays hear all about it's not about
the bachelor anymore so we all gave up
on that so you can go back to listening
Margo's talking about her fabulous life
date she's been on her bestie Nicole
joins her and it's just like if you want
to know what it's like to be young and
fabulous which I really never was when I
was young I was you're still young now
when I was like actually young I had
like two moles on my face I wasn't
fabulous
um so it's nice to you know see the lens
follow her on Instagram at margashray
Tick Tock at margashray YouTube
margabashray
um where else that's it I think Margo's
on the redheads and the redheads just
dropped their final episode of the year
today so there's plenty of content to
listen to after you listen to the toast
thousand percent thank you guys so much
for listening to the toast the
millennial Morning Show where we deliver
the fast five stories you need to know
everybody through Friday on YouTube so
you're watching this on YouTube please
don't forget to subscribing this video
thumbs up also available Spotify
all the places when you listen to
podcasts find us the toast and leave a
five-star review about how
talented we are have an amazing Thursday
and we'll see you tomorrow for
Friday Friday
gotta get down on Friday everybody's
looking forward to the weekend
say bye everyone come on come on get
your ass up lazy come on get up oh he's
not coming get up come on no say bye to
everyone bye everyone